ooh free rook okay
I'll take the presents oh my gosh how I
lose that I lost that Oh
play play g5 get some g5 emotes
attacking stuff mmm it stick I'm 5 in 94
go wait what's forgot a lot my queen
it's taken when the a pond take your
first no wait what no oh that was so bad
why'd I do that
oh that was so so bad oh I went from
winning to losing now that's so sad
Oh gambit that would be too fun yeah
this is pleasant or is it
Gavin another pond finding this and this
hmm I've rook b1 whoa what is this
things are falling can take that C 3 to
its place III gambling everything hmm
not sure what's going on here
what's going on take Chuck
what does this position like weensy one
lyric I messed up but everything hanging
to move a lot faster hmm wow this is
really bad
the how I was really bad that was really
bad I just got confused in the opening
unstuck have to be very careful no no my
mouse too slow
oh that was so bad hmm oh no don't meet
me ah
oh I grabbed a pawn I should have been
aware of danger now h5 eventually or
Queen takes h5 or f5 mmm
I hope on oh thank you I hung another
pawn die hanging all the ponds oh hang a
rook to don't take it so bad okay I hung
a queen oh that spiraled downward really
quickly a curry looks Pleasant
mmm sneaky
I'll serve this move what to do night
play this move I have meeting one wait
where do I have maiden one maybe I
missed it I'll go back after the game
guy take your take on down on time again
not good let's just go for the kill
ooh good move to play this move where
was my bathing one Queen digs g2o I'm
eatin one oh wow I forgot it's raining
mates
I still focused on Queen attacking there
were too many distractions no Jack Jack
Jack
wait where's my mate where's my mates I
miss me than one again Chuck Chuck Chuck
Chuck Chuck
I guess I'm not meeting that's kind of
sad
Bishop c7 may be a threat Oh
Bishop d7 oh wow so I did I did miss
Mayton white head Bishop d7 I played b5
that's two games in a row I miss main
one that's so bad oh no I'm losing a
queen
I lost a queen but maybe I have a
fortress oh no oh this is really bad I'm
in zugzwang
I'm like completes as long
Oh the position was so good to know I
was winning until I flagged oh it was
almost epic dirty flying he's still
alive kind of
no I flagged it again oh man not sure
what to do time scramble time opponent
threatening stuff Wow good move
oh no no no I got made it again
oh no when first time losing to that
player this is so bad I should just quit